Are you afraid of haunted houses?
What about haunted castles,
or prisons, or mental asylums? We’ve all seen or
heard tales of terrible, tortured souls walking
down long and lonely hallways, looking for
people to pass their ancient pain onto. But
what about something a lot more subtle. Perhaps as
humble and unassuming as a cozy little woodshed.
An adventurer named Cait would find that,
sometimes, terrible things hide in simple places.
With every step, twigs broke under the sole
of her boot, their snaps echoing around the
emptiness of the surrounding forest. Birds
cawed down at her from their perches up above,
a grave omen, a warning not to tread further…
well, at least to anyone who actually bought
into all that superstitious stuff. Cait was far
from a believer in that sort of thing, although,
at the same time, she had more than a passing
interest in all things occult and unnatural.
For her, it was less about the actual practice
of certain things, the appeal was more about
the stories that those practices inspired.
Legends and myths, spooky tales of ghosts,
or the dead rising from their graves and,
of course, the magical mother of them all:
witchcraft. Although her fascination with
the inexplicable and macabre rarely, if ever,
overlapped with her other big passion: hiking.
Until, of course, today.
She could trek anywhere and wanted to aim
for everywhere. Through sprawling national
parks filled with vibrant greenery, up the
sides of mountains climbing up to the peaks,
to across deserts, following the almost empty
highways to get from one tiny rural town to the
next. There was something about getting
to not just know about the world but to
actively go and see it with her own two eyes, to
actually be out there in it, that felt so right.
On her current journey, Cait had taken herself
on a long trail through the heart of the American
Midwest. Lugging a heavy pack over her shoulders,
filled with her tent, sleeping bag, outdoor
cooking supplies, and all manner of camping gear,
she had set off following the winding path of the
Patoka River, which ran around or adjacent to a
few of the major cities in the state of Indiana.
Cait was hoping to follow the flow of its
main body of water all the way through to
the city of Jasper. From there, it would be
a straight shot over to the similarly named
Patoka Lake, and after she had walked
around the entire circumference of that,
it would be a long hike East towards West
Virginia, home of the Blue Ridge Mountains. Sure,
it was one hell of an ambitious trip for one
person traveling alone, but Cait liked to
keep her journeys unencumbered; having someone
else coming with her would just slow her down,
or they wouldn’t be able to keep up with
her at all. There’s no fun at all in that.
Stopping for the night, Cait lit herself a
campfire. She had to make sure to keep it
far enough from the trees to avoid starting any
potential catastrophes, but also not too close
to the wet bank of the Patoka, otherwise, her
kindling wouldn’t catch alight. There were so many
variables to consider for any aspiring camper.
Sparks from the flint that she always took on her
travels struck the dry twigs she had collected,
and soon, a gentle orange glow and wave of low
heat were radiating from it. The fire provided
Cait with just enough light to unfold and peg down
her tent as the diminishing visibility of the dusk
gave way to the encroaching nighttime darkness.
Before getting comfortable in her sleeping bag,
she put out her campfire using water from the
Patoka, then zipped up the front of her tent,
keeping a flimsy cloth barrier between herself
and the local wildlife. Not everyone found
it as easy to sleep in the woods as Cait did.
She couldn’t remember a time when the noise of
breaking twigs or the sounds of movement outside
had ever kept her awake. Even now, the rustle of
leaves and branches did little to disturb her,
regardless of whether it was just the wind…
or something else moving through the bushes.
Woken up by the sun rising, its warm light
breaking through the trees, Cait readied herself
to leave. She never stopped at the same place
for more than one night, and rarely slept for
any longer than she needed to. A nice, eight-hour
recharge of her energy reserves, and then it was
back to the open road. After a quick breakfast,
she packed up her single-person campsite, folded
up her tent, and stuffed it back into her bag.
Cait had been just about to leave when she
noticed something was missing. Her compass, it
had been in her backpack, which she kept in the
tent with her all night. Quickly scanning the
ground around her, she couldn’t see it. Weird,
but she figured she had obviously dropped it
at some point during her hike and would have
to pick up a new one when she got to Jasper. It
didn’t matter, she could just follow the Patoka
River as planned, although it didn’t quite sit
easily with her the rest of the day’s trek.
She’d packed the compass, that she was absolutely
certain of; after all, she knew it wasn’t like
her to leave it behind. But then again, had
she… could she have forgotten it entirely?
Over the next few hours, the question went round
and round in Cait’s head. As she walked along the
bank of the river, silently starting to doubt
herself, she drifted a little deeper into the
woods until, out of the corner of her eye, she
spotted something standing among the trees.
It wasn’t an animal or even a figure, but a
structure. Spending so much time out in nature,
anything man-made usually stuck out as an
obvious, unignorable eyesore to Cait. She
looked at it from a distance; it looked like an
old house, isolated out in the woods, a short walk
from the Patoka River. Checking the sky over her
shoulder, Cait noticed it was getting late again,
the daylight having gradually lowered while she’d
been wondering about why she had left her compass
behind… or if it had been taken. Deciding
to set up camp closer to the little house,
she turned and headed in to inspect it closer.
The place was far from the lap of modern luxury.
Not that Cait couldn’t live without running
water or electricity for long stints of time.
But it wasn’t a house that had been built
recently. Although she was no expert in either
archaeology or architecture, Cait didn’t
think anyone had lived there for decades,
possibly even centuries. It was almost medieval,
a single room that was completely ramshackle,
practically falling apart at the seams. Everywhere
she looked, the wood that had originally been used
to build it was either rotting away or had
been broken into splintered remains. Plants
from the forest had started growing through the
floors and the walls as if nature was trying to
reclaim this spot of land where someone had once
come to get away from the rest of the world.
Sighing, Cait shook her head as she looked
at the dilapidated house; there was no way
even she could sleep there. It was too much
of a safety risk, parts of the ceiling could
easily fall on her during the night if the wind
picked up enough. Turning to leave, she stopped
in her tracks as she noticed another structure,
much smaller, behind the house. It had been so
dwarfed in size by the slightly bigger building
that it was completely obscured from view. But
it looked to be in much better shape in terms
of its structural integrity. It was a woodshed,
its front door hanging lazily open. While not
exactly brand new by anyone’s standards, it was
at least far more intact than the main house.
Taking a few steps forward, Cait felt something
glass crunch under the heel of her boot. She
scanned the floor, instinctively checking for
any more so as not to injure herself. Even with
the low amount of sunlight fading ever rapidly, it
didn’t look like more. Kicking her boot to loosen
the shards, she made her way towards the woodshed,
not noticing that what she’d been
standing on had been a compass.
Reaching the shed, she peered inside. It was pitch
black within, almost as dark as the rest of the
forest would be in a few minutes. Taking off her
backpack and setting it down, she searched inside
for her flashlight. Retrieving it and flipping
the on switch, she looked back into the shed…
and that was when she saw it. Taking a step back,
Cait tripped over her bag, scrabbling back up
to her feet to make sure she had seen what she
thought she had. It was just lying there, still
and lifeless. For a split second, she had hoped
it was a trick of the light, just an old, decaying
lump of wood. But it wasn’t… it was a body.
The remains were charred, reduced to little
more than bones some time ago. Even the ground
next to it looked like it had been scorched,
blackened by some intense fire damage. Cait’s eyes
were so transfixed on the burned mass of bones
that a sudden sound startled her. Thunder growled
above, immediately telling her she had little
choice in what to do next. Her options were she
could either sleep outdoors and get drenched
by the rain, and possibly catch hypothermia from
being cold and wet. Or she could spend a night in
the cramped confines of this woodshed, which she
would have to share with a long dead body. Walking
back outside to retrieve her bag, she pulled out
a groundsheet and used it to cover up the bones.
It was a mostly sleepless night, and those were a
rarity for Cait. Any sleep she did get was light,
easily interrupted by as little as her own
movements, and offered her no actual rest.
But for the next few hours, she just lay awake
on the wooden floor. It wasn’t the sounds of rain
drumming against the shed’s ceiling or the booming
of thunderclaps that were keeping her awake.
Thoughts of what she was going to do about the
bones kept coming to the forefront of Cait’s mind,
should she report it to the police when she got
to Jasper? Was there even any point if she had no
idea where on the map this abandoned place was?
Frustrated, she tossed and turned, eventually
sitting up as something made a sound. It was a
low creaking, rusty metal hinge screeching for a
lack of any oiling over the years. The door was
open, swinging lazily in the decreasing winds,
its lock having long since broken.
Grumbling to herself, Cait reached for an
old shovel that had been left in the shed and went
to grab the open door. As her head poked out from
the shed, she looked around. It was the middle
of the night, nothing to be seen anywhere around.
Yet she couldn’t escape the feeling she
was being watched. Taking the shovel,
she jammed it underneath the doorframe, keeping
it closed. At last, there was quiet. Maybe now
she’d be able to get some much needed sleep, and
she did… but that’s when the nightmare started.
The dream was bizarre, unlike any Cait had ever
experienced before. She instantly recognized the
warm, flickering orange glow of a large fire
before her. Naturally, she started to pace her
way towards it, the fire’s heat washing over
her the closer she got. But as she approached,
Cait noticed something… moving amongst the
flames. Arms flailed, trying desperately
to extinguish the blaze, legs kicking and
writhing. And that was on top of the screaming.
Another figure was standing facing the bonfire,
their back to Cait as she walked closer still.
With every step, the sound of insects buzzing
could be heard, getting louder and louder. But
it wasn’t until she stepped near enough that she
saw where the noise was coming from. A swarm of
bugs was darting through the air, hovering around
the other figure; there were enough of the insects
that they formed what looked like a cloak, every
part of it moving and buzzing of its own accord.
The whole nightmare was so vivid, Cait had no
idea if it had been brought on by her exhaustion,
or that her mind was still fixated on the
bones she’d found in the woodshed, dehydration,
lack of food, or even some other influence.
It could have been any one of those factors
that had caused her to have a dream like this…
or a combination of all of them. Nonetheless,
she could feel the bugs tapping at her skin
as she walked up to the other figure, still
unable to see them clearly. The noise of insect
wings whizzed past her ears, louder than ever,
loud enough to be real. Putting a hand on the
figure’s shoulder, Cait turned them around.
It was a woman, or what was left of her. She had
huge, gaping wounds left by something that had
been cruelly buried in her face, with similar
injuries lower down at her neck, and on her
chest. There were gaps in her skin, as if chunks
of her flesh had been hacked away. Yet somehow,
she was still standing, dead but also alive at the
same time. The swarm of bugs around her moved with
her body as she turned and faced Cait, a pair of
glassy eyes staring at her. They were both blank,
completely empty, each one missing its pupil.
Opening her mouth, the woman let out a piercing,
blood curdling shriek. All around her,
the sound of the bugs got louder, almost
deafening. And as she screamed… so did Cait.
Panting and shuddering, she sat bolt upright,
shock wracking her whole body, heart thudding
against her ribcage. Instantly, the exact moment
she woke up, Cait realized that feeling was back.
She had spent so much of her time hiking through
the woods on her own that she could tell
when someone was watching her. In the dark,
she fumbled for her flashlight, and clicked it
on to reveal… the door was still jammed shut.
Apart from her, there was no one else
inside the shed… no one alive, at least.
Looking over her shoulder, she could see the bones
behind her and immediately backed away from them;
as far as she could in the tiny wooden hut.
She had covered them before going to bed,
she was certain of it. Hadn’t she? All of
a sudden, Cait felt her skin start to itch,
an intense, irritating feeling. She had
experienced the effects of poison ivy and all
sorts of plants that cause similar reactions,
but this was easily a thousand times worse.
Her skin felt like it was burning; she scraped
her fingernails down her exposed arm, trying to
suppress the itching even for a moment but it
did nothing. She scratched at the other arm,
over and over again in one spot until her flesh
was pink and raw. Still no change. Cait raked her
nails over her own body, this time leaving a deep
scratch trailing over her arm. Under the light of
her torch, she realized that she’d drawn blood.
She looked back at the bones in the scorched
corner of the shed. The skull was facing
straight towards her, hollowed-out eye
sockets staring as empty as the pupilless eyes
of the woman in her nightmare. It had done this,
it must have done, she thought. Reaching
towards the door, dropping her flashlight,
she wrenched the shovel out from where
she’d used it to wedge the entrance closed.
She stood up, kicking her sleeping bag and
backpack to the side. As hard as she could,
desperate to make the itching stop,
Cait brought the shovel downwards.
The head of it snapped the already weakened
floorboards of the shed, exposing the soft dry
earth beneath. Maybe if she buried those charred
remains, whatever was happening to her would stop.
Frantically, she started digging, hurling
shovelfuls of dirt out through the shed door.
It listed further open, creaking loudly on
its rusted hinges again, causing Cait to turn,
startled at the sound of it knocking against
the outer wall of the shed. Someone was looking
right at her, she could feel it as real
and as persistent as the itching feeling
that crawled over her skin like the tiny legs of
an army of insects. She dug further, eventually
throwing the shovel to one side and dragging
her hands through the exposed earth below,
desperately burrowing through and only stopping to
use any rocks she found to try and stop the itch.
All she achieved was drawing more blood.
Her fingers touched something soft, but solid,
and Cait brushed away to clear more of the
excess dirt, trying to uncover what it was.
It felt like a long mass just beneath the ground,
with a second similar object parallel to it. But
the further along with it she reached, the quicker
she realized what it was… a leg. Clearing more
of the dirt higher up, Cait could feel more. A
stomach, ribs, shoulders… and a head. Reaching for
her flashlight, buried under some of the dirt that
had been dug up, she pointed it at the thing she’d
found: the woman, the same one from the nightmare.
Something inside her chest moved, scratching
sharply, causing Cait to cough. And once she
started, she couldn’t stop. It was like the
itching she’d felt on the outside had now worked
its way inside and it was spreading… no, moving.
In fact, not just moving but crawling. Through her
lungs, burrowing down into her stomach and, at the
same time, upwards. The clawing of tiny legs,
digging their way up her windpipe, blocking it.
Cait couldn’t breathe, she dropped to her knees
retching as she struggled for air, spluttering
as she felt something move at the back of her
throat. That was when she heard the buzzing again.
Locusts.
A swarm of them came spilling out
of Cait’s mouth. She couldn’t scream, let alone
catch her breath. They filled the shed in seconds,
engulfing her entire body as more and more of the
desert bugs still came pouring from her mouth.
Outside, the wind kicked up again, with
enough force to blow the door to the woodshed
closed again, trapping Cait inside as the bugs
tore at her. There was a single word on the wooden
surface of the door, written in deep, black
charcoal. She’d missed it, the door had been
open when she found the shed.
The word was ‘Witch’.
The SCP Foundation would later find this
cursed cabin, and would naturally lose a
number of D-Classes to a horrific form of
locust-based suffocation. While there are
clues as to what exactly is going on in this
terrible place - from the malice of a long dead
sorceress to the lingering revenge of a woman
wrongly persecuted - definitive answers as to
the anomalous mechanisms of the shed known as
SCP-4595 still elude even the Foundation’s finest
minds. It’s a place so mysterious and dangerous
that the special containment procedures read:
“For safety purposes, no personnel
are permitted to enter SCP-4595.
SCP-4595 should only be entered by authorized
testing personnel under the supervision of the
SCP-4595 research lead. Under no circumstances
is SCP-4595-A to be disturbed in any way.”
So perhaps we’ll never truly know why a
humble wooden shed in Jasper, Indiana,
causes such horrifying effects for its victims.
The SCP Foundation thinks it’s safer to just
lock it away and forget about it, letting its
ancient wood and old bones rot in the dark.
But if you really are curious about the truth,
you can always take a walk down the side of the
Patoka River and pay the Witch a visit. If
you’re lucky, you might even get to leave…
Now go and check out “SCP-4000 TABOO” and
“SCP-3333 TOWER” to learn more about some strange
landmarks and places that it's best to avoid next
time you go hiking through the woods on your own.